jason momoa and lisa monet calling it
quits after 16 years together all right
so here's the big question
were there signs of trouble in paradise
[Music]
fireworks i fell in love
[Applause]
what's been the best thing about being
married next level
next level
it's beautiful to go through so many
different challenges in our lives and
have a partner that loves you through
all of it
we are parting ways in marriage jason
broke the divorce news in a 122 word
statement on instagram writing we free
each other to be who we are learning to
become and this is interesting less than
an hour before jason posted the split
news his director shared this pic of the
actor in malibu on his final day of
shooting aquaman 2. she looks beautiful
so after four years of marriage were
there clues to the split well this was
the last time lisa and jason were
spotted out publicly it was almost two
years ago at a tom ford fashion show
since then jason's hit premieres and
events solo are with their two kids
last month bonet hinted a change in an
interview saying she was quote
definitely learning how to be
authentically me
and for the cosby show alum there was
this um interesting backstory ever since
i was like eight years old and i saw on
the tv and uh i was like mommy i want
that one
i'm like i'm gonna stalk you for the
rest of my life and i'm gonna get you
what was your reaction did you know that
story i've heard it
so sweet
or awkward just kidding
jason and lisa have two children
together 14 year old lola and 13 year
old nicola wolf he's also close with her
ex lenny kravitz and daughter zoe last
august jason told us he's a protective
dad could you put them in one of your
movies one day would you say
man one of them wants to do it and i'm
not a fan and i don't want
them to but uh i don't know i'll try my
dampers to keep them out of it
[Music]
you